salut les épis curieux vous avez été
nombreux à me poser des questions sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur youtube avec
le hashtag dit jamie et notamment sur
l'alimentation j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à les lire et je n'en ai fait
qu'une bouchée à table
une question de w mc callaway yes d'où
vient l'eau naturellement gazeuse en
france les eau naturellement gazeuse
proviennent principalement des régions
de montagne du massif central en
particulier quand les puits ainsi à la
source chargé de petites bulles de gaz
carbonique
ce gaz carbonique provient la plupart du
temps de l'activité volcanique passer de
ces régions
les éruptions ont libéré de grandes
quantités de gaz carbonique qui se sont
retrouvés piégés dans le sol et les
roches volcaniques au fil du temps de
pluie dans s'infiltrant et en voyageant
pendant des milliers d'années sous terre
s'est peu à peu chargée en gaz
carbonique
le gaz s'est dissout dans l'eau sur son
passage laquelle est ainsi devenu
naturellement pétillant attention à ne
pas confondre au naturel ment gazeuses
et au gaz et les fier dans ce cas on a
ajouté directement dans l'eau plate du
gaz carbonique pour la rendre pétillante
comme on le fait par exemple dans le
soda une question d'école et rosalia
c'est quoi la cuisine moléculaire
voilà une question de bon goût la
cuisine moléculaire consiste à utiliser
la science pour préparer de bons petits
plats elle a été inventée par le
britannique nicholas kurti et le
français hervé this dans les années 1990
ces deux scientifiques ont étudié les
principes physiques et les réactions
chimiques qui se déroule en cuisine en
d'autres termes comprendre les réactions
qui permettent une mayonnaise le prendre
ça c'est la cuisine utilisé ses
connaissances pour réussir à rattraper
une mayonnaise raté c'est de la cuisine
moléculaire celle ci fait aussi appel à
différents outils sorti des laboratoires
la seringue les six fautes les thermaux
circulateurs rld et émulsionner or à
ultrasons des centrifugeuses ou encore
l'azoté liquide tout cela pour proposer
de nouveaux plats des émulsions de
parmesan par exemple ou de betteraves
des bulles de melons des spaghettis au
chocolat gélifiée doit pas être mal ça
pour le goûter question de philip man 1
en quelle année a ouvert le premier
restaurant le premier restaurant
français a été ouvert en
1765 par un marchand de bouillon nommé
boulanger dans son établissement il sert
des bouillons à base de viande d'herbe
de racine donnions des peas ou de pain
de quoi restaurer les forces de ses
clients c'est d'ailleurs l'étymologie du
mot restaurant qui vient du verbe
restaurée qui signifie remettre en état
redonner des forces en donnant de la
nourriture boulanger et fut nommé
restaurateurs après avoir affiché sur sa
porte sa devise venait tout ça moi vous
dont estomaqué misère et je vous
restaurer la nourriture était servi à
table et à toute heure il affichait même
le menu à l'extérieur de son
établissement pour que ses clients
connaissent les plats leurs goûts et
leurs coûts les aux curieux demande
pourquoi le carottes sont-elles orange
les 40 était blanche c'était il ya
plusieurs milliers d'années elle était
alors sauvages mais aussi toute petite
et très dur du coup nos ancêtres préféré
consommer les graines plutôt que la
racine les premières carottes de
couleurs sont sortis de terre il ya
environ mille ans du côté de
l'afghanistan
elles sont jaunes pourpre petit à petit
leur culture s'étend aux pays voisins
elle débarque sur les tables de france
d'allemagne des pays-bas 14e siècle à ce
stade toujours pas de carotte orange les
premières voit le jour deux siècles
encore plus tard pays bas elles sont
vraisemblablement issu du croisement de
carottes jaunes et rouges à l'origine de
la couleur un pigment plus le carotène
son succès est immédiat sûrement un peu
à cause de la couleur car le range est
celle des princes de cette région mais
pas seulement 7 40 est aussi très
charnue et plus sucré que les carottes
blanches et puis à la différence des 40
rouge elle ne déteint pas dans l'eau de
cuisson et ne colorent pas les autres
aliments d'où vient l'expression en
faire tout un fromage une question de tr
klm a noté je suis arrivé on l'emploie
en général pour se moquer de quelqu'un
qui exagèrent qui donne une trop grande
importance à une chose futile on
pourrait logiquement faire un parallèle
entre son sens et la fabrication du
fromage un produit complexe pourtant
élaboré à partir d'ingrédients des plus
simples le led cette expression n'est
pas aussi vieille que la recette du
fromage et la paresse seulement dans les
années 1920 or depuis le début du 20e
siècle le mot fromage en argot désigne
la place laissé en blanc sur les
affiches de théâtre sur laquelle on
vient inscrire en grosses lettres le nom
des vedettes du spectacle se pourrait-il
alors que ce clin d'oeil et donné
naissance à l'expression en faire tout
un fromage peut-être en tout cas quelle
bonne idée de mêler le plateau de
théâtre à celui du fromage une question
d'alexandra pourquoi le miel se périment
t-il jamais à condition alexandra d'être
bien conservés dans ta peau hermétique à
l'abri de l'humidité et de la lumière le
miel peut effectivement se conserver des
années il y à au moins trois bonnes
raisons à cela d'abord parce qu'il
contient naturellement des molécules
antimicrobiennes comme tendez bien
l'oreille leur peroxyde d'hydrogène la
même molécule qui se trouve dans l'eau
oxygénée nous oxygéner qui d un fait
ensuite le miel contient très peu d'eau
il est composé d'environ 80 % de sucre
pas tout à fait le même m que le sucre
de table dans le miel c'est
essentiellement du fructose issus du
nectar des fleurs plus simple quoi qu'il
en soit comme c'est du sucre c'est un
environnement qui n'est absolument pas
favorable à la croissance des bactéries
en gros elle si dessèche enfin le miel
et acides ce qui là encore ne plaît pas
du tout aux microbes c'est d'ailleurs
pour toutes ces raisons que le miel peut
également être un bon pansement il
protège les plaies et empêche les
microbes de s'y développer voilà
pourquoi le miel plaît
pourquoi le sel conserve la viande parce
qu'ils absorbent et retient l'humidité
le sel a la particularité de faire
sortir l'eau des cellules qui composent
l'avion on appelle ce phénomène l'osmose
l'eau s'échappe des cellules pour diluer
le sel afin que la concentration en sel
minéraux s'équilibrent entre l'extérieur
et l'intérieur des cellules or les
bactéries responsables du pourrissement
de la viande ont besoin d'eau pour se
multiplier en absorbant l'eau présente
dans la viande le sel réduit la quantité
d'eau disponible pour ces
micro-organismes qui du coup ne peuvent
plus se multiplier c'est pourquoi le sel
aide à conserver la viande il ya
d'ailleurs des siècles que l'homme se
sert de cette technique et c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui de
nombreuses spécialités de charcuteries
sont encore confectionné en utilisant
cette propriété du sel comme le
saucisson ou le jambon de bayonne est
d'ailleurs les mots saucisson ou salami
par exemple sont des dérivés du latin
fluxus qui signifie ça les
retrouver c'est jamais du lundi au
vendredi à 16h55 sur france 5 où dès
maintenant sur france 3 tv le lien est
sous cette vidéo et surtout n'hésite à
vous abonner et activer la cloche faites
le savoir
[Applaudissements]